folks we're doing it we are doing it the
small
booktuber tag it's happening cheers
there's like nothing in this glass i'm
so over
i'm so over this i'm not even enjoying
this like why am i doing this for the
for like a video
anyways i'm genuinely excited to be
doing this book tag
my my friend over at galactic reads
tagged me
in the small booktuber tag she made a
wonderful small booktuber tag
herself which i really enjoyed watching
and learned about her you're going to
learn all about me
all about this small booktuber and we're
going to have some fun along the way so
buckle in pal that was aggressive i did
not mean that to be so aggressive
first question introduce yourself not
really a question
my name is jake i
am 23. i currently am an
english major a student i go to ucla
i live in los angeles with my wife and
our two dogs
who are my absolute world who i love so
much
that i don't know what else there is to
say i'm from
arizona i didn't intend to be an english
major though i went into school
originally
for film and i lived in san francisco
for a short period
when i was studying film moved back to
arizona
kind of tried to discover myself still
working on that but
ended up moving out here meeting the
love of my life i probably wouldn't
well i definitely wouldn't be finishing
school if it weren't for my wife
anyways we're that's enough introduction
for me i'm
what am i doing just revealing my life
story god how
long have you been on booktube i've been
on booktube for
like two months i think i think my three
months my first video i
i think was the caledon video wait no
there's a video earlier and that was
from
like a whole last year ago i made a
video about politics
and avengers end game i was trying to
make kind of like a good old
like video essay i didn't continue
making videos for a year because
it just wasn't uh i didn't have that
much to say you know i made that video
and i didn't feel any urge to make more
whereas kind of in the booktube
community i feel like there
is a community of people talking that's
that's very you know close-knit
what types of videos do you make um i
don't know i don't know i make i make
book reviews
i talk about politics a little in bed
and books
trying to a little bit hopefully i can
talk about movies a little bit more in
the future
arranged around the theme of books
what do you love about booktube everyone
is just
very friendly and very considerate of
one another like what else is there to
say about loving booktube i mean it's
just
booktube is a community youtube's the
platform booktube is just what we call
ourselves what types of books do you
read i read a mixture of
fantasy and science fiction and i love
classics
and poetry i love poetry so like give
you an idea of like the kind of books
that i
would like to have on like a trip bring
like a long poem let's say
garbage by arm and then i bring short
story collection of ray bradbury
wrap it up with children of dune or
something you know i like to have a
little bit of everything when i
when i travel what's your favorite video
that you've made
my favorite video that i've made is the
raiding
dune book covers video just because it's
kind of enjoyable even for me to watch i
don't really like watching my own videos
but that one's enjoyable because i
actually i really like looking at the
dune
book covers i would want to do more
videos like that where i
kind of review book cover art so now i
get to the part where i get to tag
other small booktube channels quite a
list but i only have such a long list
because there are so many hard-working
great booktubers out there right now
so moonlight library very funny great
great videos great booktuber
david diserro extremely kind person who
who makes very professional well-edited
videos
booktube with simon this is someone i i
just discovered recently
what a ch like really interesting
content sandra gibbons
wonderful person making great wheel of
time content she just made a video about
voltaire which was very good and
entertaining also
sofia clef she's making videos about
classic books so if you love classic
literature like i do
she's making wonderful books about
dostoyevsky and leo tolstoy and so many
others
fantasy talk what what can you say great
channel
and he does funny ass skits that i love
to watch
and shipwrecked library like come on we
got started at like the the same time so
i always want to
shout out her channel because she's very
funny and covers
a lot of the similar books that i like
to talk about a few more and i'll i'll
try to
list this off real quick because i don't
want to annoy people but christina j
love story starred pages the book
stamp and fina ready reading
there are so many more i could say but i
just want to
spread the love and talk about these
channels thank you to
galacticreads for tagging me on this
there will definitely be a lot of videos
to come so stick around
we'll see what happens there's a whole
world of
content waiting yeah bye-bye